i am so excited to see you right now
it's wonderful to see you
uh i mean how are you feeling with the
fact there's only 10
episodes left of this iconic show has it
kind of
set in that it's coming to an end um
it actually well it came to an end for
us filming
a while ago so it's kind of surreal that
now it's gonna be
on you know display and i can't wait for
everybody to see it because
it's it was just such a great ride such
a cool
experience and um yeah for everybody to
see now the the final 10 episodes
it's more like finally finally i know
so let's talk i don't know if you
remember the emotions when you did end
the show what was it like saying bye to
the cast and crew do you
remember that feeling yeah i couldn't i
couldn't even say anything
i uh i was wearing this very beautiful
dress in the last uh
you know thing that we were filming and
all i could think of saying was i'm just
going to keep the dress
and they were like is that all you're
going to say i was like if i say
anything i'm going to cry and then i
think i started crying so
yeah the emotions were running high
what was that last seem like with
alexander to be able to
i guess say bye to that relationship of
bjorn and gun healed
it was yeah it was emotional too
it was such a great working relationship
we uh became really good friends me and
alexander
and uh we worked together so much
throughout the last two seasons that
yeah it was hard it was really hard
have you been zooming with him are you
have you been watching the show as a fan
oh yeah i've been a fan from season one
that's when i got on it i was determined
to get on this show
um but yeah i'm i'm super excited to see
the final 10 episodes because i haven't
seen
you know all the other stories and and
um
character arcs coming to an end so i'm
excited
uh so now you talk about this beat
there's oh my gosh okay
so this trailer comes out there's all
these great moments but i have to ask
about
i think this is the beautiful dress that
you're talking about because you're
in this gorgeous white dress it looks
like a wedding dress
is she going to be sacrificing herself
well um there there were a few beautiful
dresses
and that is one of them for sure
um the yeah it looks like a wedding
dress but then again gun hill got
married in a
in a red dress when she got married to
bjorn so
we never know um you know we'll see
[Music]
it's an epic scene i mean that's the
thing that got my attention and we saw
bjorn
hurt in the first part of season six
part a
uh i know you can't tell me if he's
gonna die or not but in the viking
tradition usually it means the character
is gone like the main characters
which you invested in is always they're
always gone
uh but will we get to see both of you in
the final episode
well you're just going to have to watch
and
see because i can't tell you right here
yeah i think you know once you see
somebody get hurt you automatically
think that's it because
you know there were no you know modern
medicine back then but you know
not everybody is you know the son of
odin
or rodney sure so you never know you
never know
if he died would that be the best ending
for for vikings um well i loved his
character
in the whole in the whole um you know
six season seven so i would i would like
to see you know season seven and eight
and nine and ten
of bjorn ironside and good hill and all
the others but
well you know i think i think the end um
is gonna leave people happy and
sad obviously too but happy with the
conclusion of
of our stories i think michael hurst
wrote it
so well and you know i'll get emotional
talking about it even when we
all had to say goodbye but i think the
fans are going to really love it
did you ever have that fear when you
read the script like the fact that so
many of these characters do die off did
you ever feel like okay here's the
script
i'm still there or like like oh my gosh
gun hill's gonna be gone
when you see that somebody's gonna get
killed off it doesn't
uh usually come as a surprise um those
people who
who get their characters you know killed
on this show
um they'll they'll find out before a
couple of episodes or a few episodes
yeah so it's not a surprise but it's
always hard to read
and you know you'll see somebody that
you've been working with for a long time
you know gets
like will there be another epic battle
in the
the last 10 episodes oh i think for sure
we'll see some battles yeah i don't
think that's it of battles that's uh
yeah
one of the best things about it you know
right
and this your your character is
absolutely amazing a warrior she's
intelligent she's kind she's beautiful
i mean for you to take on a role like
this i mean
it must mean a lot to you it really does
um i was supposed to be named gunhild if
i would have been born a day later my
mom's best friend her name is gundill
then
i was born the day before her birthday
so every year
my mom tells me the day after my
birthday you know good hill was supposed
to be your name if you would have been
born this day and i
you know when i got the part i called my
mom and i said guess my name and she
goes
so you get gun health you're gonna heal
right so it really
it really meant so much to me to get you
know this
strong viking shield maiden you know
warrior but also
get to be you know vulnerable feminine
you know loving and it was amazing to be
able to
you know get that you know beautiful
character
written for me yeah did you take
anything from the set
to keep i got some things yeah i did get
a couple of uh uh
arm rings nice um yeah
i was gonna take that dress that's
that's the one thing that i really
wanted but i didn't get it
yeah the one you sacrificed yourself and
i know yes oh okay
nice try uh who would you say is the
most
legendary viking from all the seasons
um i would have to say lagretha
catherine is amazing she welcomed
me and so like it was like being you
know welcomed into a family
and um yeah she's just she's amazing
she was she was there you know we had
some really epic battle scenes together
and
and i think throughout the seasons um
you know that there is no you know you
could say ragnar you could save your and
ironside you could say
ivar but i think lagertha
has been she's the queen
so now that you finished shooting that
was a a while back our arc actually we
were there on set with our crew and you
got a chance to chat with carlos so we
got a little bit of tidbits here and
there of some of the scenes
and i'm not allowed to say either what
we have
but what have you been working on since
then um
i've been working on a few things
most recently i did
assassin's creed valhalla so it's a
little bit of a
you know viking you know connection
there and
uh i'm doing now an animated series
um for arc yeah so from the
from the video game so my voice is being
um
you know broadcasted here and there so
that's kind of cool and then smaller
things here and there but yeah
just uh also been just really enjoying
time with my son
this year especially less work and
you know not not as much travel so me
and my son
he's seven he's on vikings actually he's
on episode
13 i think it is nice there's a little
cameo in there and he's very excited
about it
he's been asking me for about a year
when is my episode coming out
so yeah he's uh he appears in a little
in a little scene there so yeah how are
you coping through all of this
through the isolation how is it there
it's not
that bad we have you know our mountains
and
rivers and waterfalls and just being
able to go in nature
and i know not everybody can you know if
you live in a big city and you can't go
outside as much
so it hasn't been that bad here but yeah
it's definitely strange
now there's a spin-off that's happening
do you have any
information on that i know a couple
people
who've been working on it but i'm not
allowed to say but i have no idea
oh you're cutting away i would love to
know i would love to go visit
set and you know see what's happening
but no no yeah i think it's going to be
great i mean i i
you know i wouldn't expect anything else
from from the whole team
you